[Music]  it's time for et's social study your  quick look at what the stars are posting  online Beyonce continues her reign as  Queen of maternity wear the hot mama  dressed her growing belly of twins with  another figure-hugging gown Tarak al  Musa rocks a new do between his  fresh-cut new car and hot new bod even  the flip or flop star is asking himself  is this a midlife crisis crisis averted  for Maksim Chmerkovskiy the dancing with  the stars pro gave fans an update on his  calf injury they three progress good  news he can walk on it again give it a  little one and finally Canadian Prime  Minister Justin Trudeau challenged  Matthew Perry to a schoolyard rematch  after Perry revealed a jimmy kimmel he  once punched Trudeau when he was 10 I  thrives the only kid in school that we  could be up the friend star tweeted  sunday i think i will pass at your  request for a rematch sir given that you  currently have an army at your disposal  [Music]  you